[Music]
three two one action the record or we
talk about whatever and pouring some
tequila we're wearing some bling bling
bling shoutouts to James veto for
hooking us up with the jewels man by
letting us borrow that's what he means
but yeah hooking us that this is what
Jeff wants me know where that suffering
early so I love it well with the Blazer
too that's why like the whole package
here like with the Blazer with the white
yeah well I got something for you to buy
actually he looks like he's ready to
hang out at a bar in Vegas he's a he's a
host for something I was like I know
where the cocaine is you know where the
strippers in the valium is in the
bathroom on the mirror and then you look
like this really dope like don't think
this corn producer but like a hipster
but like a cool hipster
porn producer okay not like like a lame
hipster okay so more of the Lincoln
Heights hipster not the not the other
place you like you look like you used to
work at Amoeba Records and you line it
closed down yeah and you're like man
we're they gonna open another record
store dude he would like own it though
cuz that chain makes it look bollocks I
sell motorcycle parts and accessories
for cafe racers custom custom yeah
that's key and a chain of tattoo parlors
that that would I buy more okay you just
need some tattoos then combining those
things now really yeah motorcycle shop
barber shop tattoo shop barbershop 3
ultimate hipsters own mother and I
scream you well that's the next thing
you and copy
well coffee to your bar any bar you sell
seventy five thousand dollar car stereos
yeah for seven thousand dollar cars
oh yeah that sounds about right why do
people do that [ __ ] I don't know
it is a riot I love those classic 2000
dollar cars that they just hook the [ __ ]
up with fifty thousand dollars worth of
things amazing yeah it's such a horrible
investment I can't think of a worse what
I feel attacked me oh because that's
basically what my bike is
like any attachment on there it's fully
custom like the ground yeah any-any
customized thing I did too it cost more
than the bank how the like but ourselves
are probably it's cost more in the book
I bought for like 700 bucks oh damn
your cafe racer yeah I bought my but
they're not like the carburetor I
replaced it with five for like $800
thank God how much would you pay for it
else what how much would you pay for
right now right now for your card that
you just you tricked out that mod bike
yeah what's that one like to say I'd pay
like 20 grand for if anyone who's a
hearing so you need to meet one guy
who's like you who's like 20 grand this
is a [ __ ] ste you got to go to hipster
Craigslist what is that
hipster Craigslist hipster Craigslist
joy just type it in his suit critic on
hipster Craigslist we should make a
hipster Craigslist I'm gonna make one up
huh buy a domain right now do you think
hipsters consider themselves hipsters no
that's the rule of being hipster because
you don't say I'm not a hipster you
immediately say I'm not do they even
exist anymore or is that the honey what
are you Bart have you ever driven
through Silver Lake the whole city is
hip there's a little hipster just like
considered hipsters like defines a hips
even the carbon they got the curly
mustache these are the concept [ __ ]
call your moustaches and beards but I
thought that was like a 2018 thing and
they're not around and they look like
they're like that anymore when they look
like when they're an ironworker from the
1920s
no steampunks different they live in the
Dallas play they live in the desert and
yeah they look like they're a little bit
in society that's pumping yeah yeah yeah
so there's that still do this they don't
have missing the beating police force
and so for like does this and they'll
have beanies yeah and they drive home
heavy buckets and then drive Dick Tracy
cop cars yeah I go to the hipster
Craigslist and the the number one thing
that popped up was this Craigslist ad
for its the titled hipster ass hipster
bike for hipsters I'm selling my Vista
career seven road bike is that a hipster
bike it's the correct I think a bicycle
oh yeah it's just right bicycle hipsters
do like bicycles exceeds right yeah
hipsters don't ride motorcycles no they
do tom dooley do yeah it'll be like a
piece of junk denim so what did they
identify as like if we call them hipster
hipster sexual yeah
and they drive more like mopeds I'd say
right scooters best but best buys I
grasp oh yeah no they come with bags on
the front of course hipsters ride that
[ __ ] because the because the bad boys of
the hipsters were that they do they do
the cafe racers and the motorcycles and
in the more tame ones that look like
Where's Waldo they have the scooters in
the bicycle yeah yeah the more relaxed
guy yeah yeah spectrum offense yeah
they're like that they're like the vice
host guys dude Nicky when we first met
she thought I was a hipster which is the
most offensive [ __ ] mustache you know
I used to wear like plaid shirts and
[ __ ] and I weren't stuff from Urban
Outfitters and I didn't know Urban
Outfitters oh yeah yeah well I got worse
I don't know why but I pictured old
maybe when you said that cuz I would you
like that the old navy kind of plaid oh
okay no this was this was like you know
[ __ ] hipster plan I guess I didn't
even know I was just buying [ __ ] cheap
where he just comes already drink all
you do I just that plaid look cool those
those salt Valley shirts they were
[ __ ] dope with the South Valley they
were like the the Urban Outfitters
shirts with the buttons on them and [ __ ]
and they were like
part of her master's well they always
blow pretty expensive oh sorry
no hi so one time I got a pair of diesel
jeans at Urban Outfitters right but they
were marked down marked down marked down
because Urban Outfitters thought that
they were gonna [ __ ] get in the
diesel jeans market for some reason but
people who go there like hey I'm looking
for like cheaper [ __ ] and so I got a
pair of diesel jeans for 40 bucks whoa
thank you I've always got the deal
always was that how much they usually
cost 300 Oz damn who are you yeah we're
businessmen yeah we just released a half
a million dollar course for 99.99% off
it's only twenty dollars right now right
now and they right now leave below you
guys could check out no joke man we have
a course going on - that's why we're
actually wearing these jewels courtesy
of James betta from Todd jewelers he's
hooking a groupie we're weighing
approximately there's approximately
$100,000 yeah but you want to guess how
much each of these chains cost how much
do you know the mold yeah it's really
pretty other diamonds and yeah there's
time he owns a jewelry store so it's so
crazy dude and you know what in a time
like this with The Cove Eve people are
still buying your nuts right there's
people making [ __ ] money right in
person they go they go in person to the
jewelry store oh no not only we can buy
jewelry shoes you just want to check the
bottom line you could buy stuff on let's
do your wife's anniversary all kind of
[ __ ] show through me yeah he made this
this custom it's a custom dragon and
gorgeous whether it's a homosexual
dragon bro what the [ __ ] you talking
about what you want what's almost sexual
about this dragon dragons making it it's
[ __ ] kissing itself what would you
call that's like a two-headed snake it's
good thing in jail so it's like that guy
who sucks his own dick yeah yeah that's
they see exactly it right like that it's
like that yeah self love this one's a
crusted in diamonds it's 22 karat gold
it's super crazy dude I'm gonna get 30
grand
you can folio
yeah they're all diamond-encrusted I
know nothing about Julie's I don't even
know where to start the price at okay so
first I would go if it's gold
I would weigh the gold and see how much
that cost and then you would go based
off of current value of gold per ounce
and you see the craftsman say it's yeah
and then that you see that's how a lot
of jewelry stores make money is because
the art part is what goes up in value up
it's custom and also Sojo is more the
gold guy more the diamond guy so
diamonds you got vs 1 vs 2 clarity so
we're talking like the ultimate [ __ ]
clarity right there and also it's all
about the color right what does the S
stand for you know very sleek very sleek
a virtually sleek very very smooth very
swag very smooth guys virtually
sleeplessly nice okay well cut Steve
please princess diamond yeah oh all
right what do you how much do you think
this goes for right here uh 20k I don't
guessing 30 are those diamonds in the
chains
yeah there's diamonds in the chain and
then the two like each I feel like a
rapper right now yeah 40k will kind of
carry it close to warning yeah
forty-four forty-five you said the whole
thing was 100k so I was looking at
everything and I was like that one
weighs the most it looks like this is
what has the most art to and so
intricate in each one of these ye each
one of these are ten to fifteen
depending on $35,000 or I'm gonna cry
now or as I call it g-wagen down payment
money hips we are aware jewelry like
it's because they can't take that from
you so they use it as a way to build
himself out of jail so if they get
caught they're like you can't you can't
go to a they can't the cops can't take
this they could take your cash because
it's an accessory to whatever the crime
you yeah committing so then when they
have a lot of their wealth here and in
the
Bonz guy comes it's like boom I'll use
that as collateral cause it's considered
like their clothes so they can't stay
they can't take yeah it's like what if
you have a wedding ring man the cops
can't take that I got a wedding chain
right or just it's just jewelry you know
it's fashion your clothes yeah and I was
like wow that's interesting
not that he sells to pimps or anything
like that I just thought it was a fun
fact south to pimps even post mates to
pimps also get very hungry sometimes
like myself so right now I'm a pimp
off-duty because I can't meet with my
host so usually I get I make all my food
at home right now but I do crave an
occasional boba so these days I found
this place next to my house that makes
handcrafted boba it's really really good
and then they post minutes they come and
they still obey all the quarantine rules
and they just drop it off they bring the
doorbell I looked through the hall and I
see when they leave and I go pick it up
and I get it their post mates know I
love food and that's why I love post
mates they deliver food from like every
restaurant I could think of like which
one
Danny's true
I like Danny's but post mice doesn't
just deliver Denny's or burgers and
sushi they actually make life easier
with grocery delivery and whatever I can
think of delivery to convenience stores
clothing stores you name it so no more
trips to the store no more late-night
fast food nuns so no more trips to the
store no more late-night fast food runs
I don't even have to worry about where
to grab lunch anymore
just download post mates on iOS or
Android find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within one
hour for a limited time post mates is
giving our listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use the code off the record
that's off the record for $100 off of
free delivery credit with no minimum
purchase for your first 7 days when you
download the post mates app anything you
need anytime you need it postmates it
link in a description box below off the
record baby listen I just wanna say
thank you guys so much for your very
understanding drivers because I
accidentally sent a post mates all the
way across town from where we were
living I my thumb hit the wrong area of
the map oh no and if it came to you over
there first Wow it cost the city they
went all they came all the way back
across the city hope you didn't just tip
the minimum well of course it did of
course of course but man are they
[ __ ] understanding they [ __ ] up one
time when I ordered like eight boxes the
flop a girl and then we were at doubt I
hate boxes and I sent it over here Oh be
honest with yourself
that did not happen one time that
happened probably like four times that
have been so many times where you guys
are here and you're supposed to get
Starbucks or delivered here but then
ends up going to your house it's not our
fault were so balling up to offices so I
get confused looking at all the office
choices where to send it to there's a
necklace that I've been so obsessed with
because we've been binging jewelry and
no the new charms cuz like the old charm
is so bad but it's like nostalgic to me
cuz I used to watching when I was a kid
growing up don't want the Alyssa
Milano's yeah that one
that one's bad it's so bad a new Tom
doesn't have those same cast no it's a
completely different cat what about rose
mcgowan oh she's been that one too is
the old one no this new one it's still
based off of like similarities of the
old on but I my opinions done a lot
better but it's still really cheesy
anyway this one what are the girls she
wears this this necklace worth a
yin-yang necklace and it's like all in
gold and it's so pretty and I've been
like so obsessive trying to find it and
I can't find it anywhere so then you
mentioned your friend on my god yeah he
could probably counterfeit that for you
perfect what's that called
why why they call it that what I mean
where they call counterfeited oh because
the design is stolen oh the gold isn't
counterfeit nobody singing design like
it said oh that's true
we can't copy they can't copyright it
right I don't know and there's a
lighting you know it's [ __ ] dope
because um so I got into jewelry like
ages ago because I was like wait gold is
already expensive right and you could
make it even more expensive with the
design that you put into it and the way
the artwork like I like metalwork
so like when [ __ ] uh Nelson was
making straight up the scraps
yeah the squat rack I was there like oh
my god this is so sick and I'm just
recording him like and then I'm like the
metals melted and [ __ ] right I don't
know why I should drive it it's like
it's like it's like a caveman with the
[ __ ] fire you're like alright yeah
but what's more yellow are your welding
videos yeah but what's even crazier
though is the interest Casilla in the
artwork between behind this and the
price and it just combines everything
that I like put together I never really
got it two diamonds but metals like gold
silver all those things I thought I was
[ __ ] sick right but now with all the
technology and the computer and [ __ ]
like that they could do some really dope
stuff compared to back in a day when it
was all hand yeah this isn't really my
style like having to dragon heads that
close because it does look like two
dragons making out but if you add it's
like a little tiny little fists to them
yeah it's like the little little fist
bumping like dragons going like this and
I can mess with it yeah I can rock up
when it comes to that kind of stuff can
you supply your own gold and use but hey
I have [ __ ] gold like nuggets and
then can you melt it down yeah you mind
yeah then you mind I panned it yeah
exactly I pant I sell pandas yes exactly
and then you ain't gonna have I'm sure
because they they have all the equipment
to melt it like I sold them about 20 of
my gold coins and bricks right and in he
but by the same week here he melted it
turned it into jewelry and sold it Wow
so I'm like what the [ __ ] and and
they're worth more as gold coins than
like regular just gold bars and gold
piece right cuz people collect them yeah
so I'm like you melted that [ __ ] he goes
yeah I make way more money like melting
it and turning them into dope designs
you know what you should do you should
make gold coins
[Laughter]
dude it's expensive right now to like
gold gold is like eighteen seventeen
hundred dollars and just earlier this
year was like twelve hundred ounces per
ounce and when people say an ounce of
gold they they do it by troy ounces
which is not regular it's like 32 grams
or some [ __ ] and in regular ounces like
28 grams so I don't know I don't know
it's man yeah it's it's called troy
ounce is it like a baker's dozen what
does the baker's dozen
13 13 13 yeah yeah it's like there's
always that so they test the whole batch
my eating one of them and they still
sell you the one with the bite market
they just saw the dozens but that the
Baker part of the dozen the 13 points or
the Baker's oh I don't know maybe
someone can explain why it's called troy
ounce but it's not the same that's my
code Troy Troy bites it yep it's real
[ __ ] no idea a couple of grams yeah
in the comments somebody in the comments
tell me why it's a troy ounce I don't
want to gue it's a bridge on video no
okay good crazy
well no cuz usually there's like there's
like four comments maybe max on on
patreon ones cuz it's old it's a
different group oh and well the reason
why we did get these though is because
me and Steve are money masters we're
teaching a course on how to become
straight-up Bhalla hey like I showed you
guys you don't have to spend the money
to look rich you just have to have a
rich friend I'll let you borrow project
my project well I've gotta be the guy on
the passenger side and I'm trying to
holler at them thank you I forgot yeah
yeah so we're the money masters and we
definitely would want you guys to join a
program because it's gonna be real sick
and how much is that it's like you're
giving a good discount on so Randi nine
point nine nine percent discount
normally it would be
we had some independent arbitrators come
in and they evaluate the program up half
a million dollars and we said you know
what guys we fired them and we said get
the [ __ ] out of here we're gonna charge
a ninety-nine point out there Jeff Bezos
nephew evaluated it and said that this
should be sold for half a million
dollars and we said uh-uh
buddy we're not gonna rob people get the
[ __ ] out of here we're only gonna charge
$20 what if he tells Jeff Bezos about
he's promised he wouldn't because he
signed a contract that we had we had him
son yep but we you know we think it's
the quarantine and all that like people
don't got that much money to spend
anyway so who's got half a million
dollars laying around aside from us you
know so we said twenty bucks is probably
a real decent price no dirty cop it's
already discount from the scam 99.9 yeah
what do you want Megan I get what you
want pend spend like $9.99 maybe three
cents do you sense three cents all right
[ __ ] you doing a cold or something like
that like at twenty like we both have
one friend code so I'm not using my
friend going on to if you use your
friends what I'll do
[Laughter]